president biden will visit the gulf
coast today to survey the damage from
ida and it comes at a delicate time for
the president he faces multiple crises
at home and abroad ranging from the
storms devastation to the chaotic
withdrawal from afghanistan our senior
white house correspondent wishiang joins
us now wiesha good morning to you you
are sitting in on face the nation this
weekend and there is a lot going on
let's talk about the climate crisis as
the president calls it
how will these storms and the wildfires
affect his push for
action on climate and also
infrastructure which could be used to
address these flooding issues
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody we do have a packed show
because everything that happened this
week especially what we just saw is
something that the president wants to
really focus on he says what we are
seeing play out on both coasts the east
and the west with the hurricane and the
wildfires is just another call to action
for lawmakers as he is trying to push
them to pass those twin infrastructure
proposals that really weave in
infrastructure for the country as well
as climate proposals that could help
combat future disasters like this and so
he says that they need to act right now
of course bad timing for the president
because just yesterday west virginia
senator joe manchin said that there
should be a strategic pause on that
democratic reconciliation bill which
really has all the major components of
the president's uh climate uh goals
there so um the president does face
challenge there but he says you know
just look at what's happening for any uh
case to to move forward with these
legislations
out of texas this week we saw a novel
law effectively banning abortion in that
state for many women severely
restricting it at the very least and
there's likely to be copycat bills and
laws in other states that's moved the
issue to the white house what is
president biden saying about it
so tony the white house is saying that
is exactly why there's so much urgency
to do something to deal with the
immediate impact of that
law and so the president yesterday
announced that he has called on several
agencies to work with white house
lawyers in addition to his gender policy
council to try to answer what they can
do not only when it comes to providing
care
for women who are looking for it but
also any legal tools so we are going to
be talking to congresswoman veronica
escobar who
represents many of those women
in texas about what she wants the
federal government to do and how
realistic it is to do anything
given the fact that you know congress
really has the power here to take
long-term action but we want to know
what she's hearing from her constituents
and from health care providers who are
trying to deal with this fallout because
it just just happened
the president last night made a surprise
trip to walter reed i'm wondering how
that went since he's been hammered
recently for the way that he handled the
withdrawal from afghanistan
well you know gail the president has
often uh portrayed himself as the
consoler in chief and as someone who can
really connect with these families and
you know i think that he has stressed
not only directly to them but certainly
publicly um
how much he can
understand what they're going through
having uh lost an adult son of his own
but he has a lot more to deal with on
the afghanistan front because of course
there are still americans who remain in
afghanistan who are trying to leave as
well as those afghan allies so um you
know he has a long road ahead of
answering questions and i think the big
question that americans have right now
especially with the 20th anniversary of
9 11 coming up is whether we are safer
now than before so we'll be talking to
sue gordon who has more than 40 years
experience in the intelligence community
to try to answer that and gail i think
you know to your question about the
troops one person who um has more
experience here at cbs news than anybody
is our david martin and he will be
opening his reporter's notebook to
reflect about how this war and how the
exit has impacted the country
all right we're looking forward to that
yeah it's very busy newsweek and it'll
be a very busy news weekend lisa zhang
thank you very much she will be sitting
in for margaret brennan on face the
nation this weekend and we will talk
with texas democratic congresswoman
veronica escobar about her state's
controversial new abortion law and also
joining her will be new jersey governor
phil murphy to talk about the
devastating northeast flooding as well
as dr anthony fauci good luck to wishes
we just still there because i think
isn't this her first it is
gradually
we just gone he's gone
she's busy
i watch every sunday looking forward to
that
we just wanted to say we're cheering you
on sunday because isn't this your first
face
it is my first face and you know we are
thrilled to welcome margaret back from
maternity leave next week but this is a
treat to be able to do this and and talk
to um our panel because it is a packed
panel and of course for me you know
labor day weekend meant one thing when i
was growing up it meant back to school i
know as a parent myself i still have so
many questions as all parents do about
what that means for our kids so dr fauci
will be able to really talk about the
data that's coming out today with regard
to children and cases and
hospitalizations
and talk about potential new variants
that might be
spreading so gail
pack show and thank you very much
listen i'm a big weijang fan y'all are
yeah we all we all are we all are and in
the words of tiffany haddish she ready
we'll be watching you on sunday cheering
you on